do you get intimidated when you're
working with an elton john
music is where i can hide like you know
music is where i feel the most secure
that's why my voice holds a lot of value
to myself and to other people
and um i've had to kind of work on my
relationship with that and find other
things that
i love about myself too because you know
you look at other athletes
or their whole careers are built on
these big muscles
you know and it's like i've got these
two little tiny cords and everything is
balanced
on top of these little whenever you get
scoped and you actually see it it's
really crazy when you see
how much force and pressure you know
everything my stability in my life
is balanced on these tiny little chords
and
when you look at these other athletes
which is what i consider myself to
really be
and that's why it's just so important
that now i've been really training
because i
i i learned what happens when you don't
train
um and it's just really important to to
take care of these
you know things that that is the reason
why all of us here have
something to do today so it's just it's
a lot of pressure it is a lot of
pressure and i know a lot of singers who
have lost their voice
literally lost their voice i had a
surgery last november
um i was one of the younger artists that
had ever had this surgery when i was
looking at
you know the stephen tyler's on the wall
and i'm like i'm not here yet
why do my chords look like stephen tyler
and like
i you know i'm looking and i'm like
thinking about the longevity and
sustainability
that he's had and then i'm looking at
myself i'm i was
26 and i'm still i'm getting this
surgery that
six-year-old touring artists are getting
but i'm feeling really good and i've
done the
rehabilitation that it takes so i never
want to do that again
so in taking assessment of your vocal
cords and your career and having this
understanding is that why
you became sober that you said if i
drink
um [ __ ] my voice up i'm making bad
decisions
how hard was it for you to get sober
it's the decision making
when i want to do something i do it and
there's just no question about it and so
it wasn't as challenging as it can be
for a lot of people
for me drinking hasn't been that hasn't
been my demon
but it does not get me going
any further if anything it just makes me
not reach my full potential which is
unacceptable to me like i will not
accept anyone or anything that causes me
to not reach my fullest potential